eg P use have become more and more
popular in recent years and many people
are now considering buying a map of Pro
with based graphics and adding an eg PU
at something like a Vegas 64 a Radeon 7
graphics card instead of buying a fully
spec Tao 8 core Vega 20 model the idea
is that you'll get a portable MacBook to
use on the go while getting a ton of
extra performance at home with the
ability to upgrade the graphics down the
line the concept sounds great but we've
discovered that in a lot of cases you
really don't gain that much performance
and in some cases you actually lose
performance and we've also found a way
for you to check out your current
machine to see if you'll benefit from an
e GP or not so stick around into the end
to find out how in this video we tested
both the $400 Vegas 64 and $700 Radeon 7
graphics cards using the $300 razor core
X GPU enclosure which is in our opinion
the best and most reliable enclosure you
can currently buy for the cash we'll
have links to all these down in the
description below let's get started with
the Geekbench 4's graphics test as you
can see the e GPUs offer a decent jump
in raw graphics performance over vega 20
graphics in the MacBook Pro and the
Radeon 7x is the performance of the iMac
which is nice but it should be getting a
lot more than that seeing as using this
card in a Windows PC
actually gets you around 210 thousand
points the score is much lower for two
reasons
first of all II GPUs send data through
Thunderbolt 3 so there's a lot of
efficiency loss and reason number 2 is
that even though we're on Mac OS 10
point 14.5 the drivers for the card are
still not fully optimized now let's move
on to the unit in Heaven gaming
benchmark we actually start to see the
Radeon 17 with over twice as much FPS as
the Vega 20 graphics so if you're a
gamer and a GPU will actually help a lot
one thing I do want to mention is that
for the best results you should always
use an external display plug directly
into the e GPU in force each program to
use it by right-clicking on the app in
the Applications folder within finder
clicking get info and selecting prefer a
GPU now moving on to some Final Cut Pro
video editing tests we ran the standard
Bruce X benchmark which basically just
uses 100% graphics and saw a really good
performance boost over the MacBook Pro
by itself but for some reason the Vegas
64 actually did just as well we'll
explain
why this is happening in just a minute
now on to stabilizing a 20 second clip
both EGP use perform exactly the same
and only a bit faster than the MacBook
Pro by itself and here's where it gets
interesting
this test is exporting a five-minute
clip of standard h.264 4k footage which
is basically what most youtubers are
working with every day we actually got
much slower times with the egb use and
interestingly the Vegas 64 was faster
than the Radeon 7 so why the heck is the
MacBook Pro faster by itself well this
type of project is already really easy
and efficient for the standard macbook
because of the hardware decoding and
encoding with quick sync using an e GPU
adds a lot of extra steps and
bottlenecks requiring the data to go
from the CPU to the thunderbolt
controller through the thunderbolt cable
and then to the graphics to be rendered
and then back again to the cpu to be
encoded instead of doing everything
inside of the macbook pro by itself with
no bottlenecks for the previous tests
like units in heaven and bruce x the
graphics is the bottleneck so those
scenarios can use any GPU to its full
potential
now before we move onto some more
difficult tasks like read raw and Canon
raw I need to give a shout-out to our
sponsor Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of classes covering almost any creative
and entrepreneurial skill you can think
of want to get great at video editing
check out specific classes based on
their program and skills you want to
improve if you want to learn how to make
videos we would recommend low-budget
filmmaking by Maddy Brown
you'll also find classes on photography
graphic design animation web development
in even things like business because
Skillshare is sponsoring this video you
can sign up with the link in the
description and get a 2 month free trial
whether you want to fuel your curiosity
creativity or even career skill share is
a perfect place to keep your learning
and thriving and it's also incredibly
affordable with annual subscriptions at
less than $10 a month get access to
unlimited classes today by starting your
2 month free trial by using the link
below now some users are starting to
move on to h-e-b see where the MacBook
Pro by itself performs better than the
Vega 48 imac that's because it's packing
apple's t 2 chip that has hardware HT vc
encoding the reason the EGP use are
slower is the same as before and once
again the Radeon 7 is slower than the
Vega 64 now let's move on to some more
advanced editing 4.5 K Brad
brah which is heavily dependent on the
processor and not on the graphics here
we see that the iMac is the fastest
because it has the most powerful
processor with the MacBook Pro trailing
behind with or without an e GPU as you
can see in the screenshot the CPU is
completely maxed out and the eg bu is
basically doing nothing because it has
to wait on the CPU to process the raw
footage and now onto c200 bra which uses
a ton of graphics power we finally see
that you GPU speeding things up and
that's because the MacBook Pro by itself
was limited by the Vega 20 graphics in
fact you'll see in the screenshot that
even the Radeon seven graphics was the
limiting factor since it was a hundred
percent maxed out at full usage while
the CPU was chilling at just 39 percent
usage and again the iMac was faster
because it doesn't have to deal with
Thunderbolt 3 in efficiencies so these
were obviously video editing tests which
don't use just the graphics so if you're
doing something like gaming or some
other tasks that really uses tons of
graphics power you're gonna see speed
boost similar to the Bruce X and Unigine
Heaven results we got earlier but to be
honest the bump and speed isn't really
what we were expecting especially since
the Vega 48 should be much slower than
even the Vegas 64 but it isn't because
of a GPU efficiency loss even worse the
Radeon 7 per formed basically the same
as the Vegas 64 and it costs about $300
more this honestly makes us think that
Apple took the easy route of repurposing
the Vegas 64 drivers for the Radeon 7
since both the benchmarks and real-world
results are so similar while the same
GPU performs about 50% better in Windows
hopefully Apple will finally have decent
drivers for it when Mac OS Catalina
comes out this September but for now we
recommend just buying the Vegas 64 and
saving $300 if you're gonna use it in
any GPU if you're a video editor using
Final Cut Pro do not buy an e GPU for
your MacBook Pro unless you're editing
very specific footage like C 200 brah
that is very graphics intensive and even
then the performance isn't that much
better considering you have to deal with
the little glitches and issues that come
with using an e GPU like you're
displayed randomly going black out of
nowhere other apps like resolve in
Premiere Pro may see more gains from
mini GPU and we're currently testing
that and we'll post a video on the max
yuryev channel so make sure to subscribe
to that if you're wondering if you'll
benefit from using an e GPU we have a
simple test you can run to find out if
you'll gain 4 4
or not download ISTEP menu 6 from django
calm and while you're doing your
specific graphical work like 3d
animation for example click on the CPU
icon and the taskbar and if the blue
processor bar and the graphics section
is fully maxed out while the CPU is not
really being used
that means you'll benefit from an e GPU
now if both the CPU and GPU usage are
nearly maxed out that means that if you
buy an H of EU your processor will most
likely become the bottleneck and you
might not see that much performance
gains but if your CPU is completely
maxed out and your graphics is not being
used much you won't gain anything from
using an e GPU at all
now how about for other Macs should you
buy an easy bu for your iMac probably
not because of the Thunderbolt cable
inefficiencies you probably won't see
much gains at all and you'll probably
lose performance if you're using an iMac
pro now Mac Mini users will benefit the
most from any GPU because it doesn't
come with a dedicated graphics chip at
all so you kind of have to get an each
of you for heavy graphics work so there
you have it that's why most people
should not buy an e GPU for the 2019
MacBook Pro if you enjoy the video make
sure it's apt like and click the circle
above to subscribe and make sure to
check out those two videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]